so I started faking it in the mirror and
I started saying I love you I love you
thick thighs I love me back fat and all
of a sudden it started to stick and I
started to make wiser decisions with my
food wiser decisions with my actions of
going to the gym wise in decision with a
min that I was hanging out with because
I was so insecure about the woman that I
had seen in the mirror my name is Ashley
Graham and I have a model designer and
body activist and I'm 28 years old
alive 2013 Ford models totally dropped
their plus-size division all together
and I was without an agency for six
months and what I ended up doing was two
years later I started a lingerie line
because then in America I was known as
the lingerie model and that's exactly
what people wanted to see me in and now
my company is quite successful there was
never there was never like a said
strategy that I had in going and
convincing people that my body type
needs to be put out on covers of
magazines I've been doing this for 15
years it's not something that came
overnight for me so the more hard work
you put into it and the patience you
have you can get anything you want I had
to make a really hard decision I had to
make a decision between emotions and
business and I let all my emotions go
and I chose
and it was the best thing I've heard